if you are interested in stories with
happy endings that story is streaming
elsewhere
I would advise all our viewers to watch
something more pleasant instead I am
Count Olaf your new Guardian wary of
hands now we're orphans put them to work
in the mill mess economy children are
lucky to have a job at all your first
impression of me may be that I am a
terrible person when are we going to eat
but you haven't the faintest idea you
have to understand he had a very
terrible childhood don't look so down
having a very terrible childhood right
now okay
our parents are never coming back we're
all frightened Klaus mother and father
they made me promise to always look
after you let me keep my promise
you're finally safe now children just as
your parents wanted find your aunt
Josefina
she can tell you everything you need to
know do you live with our aunt Josephine
I am your aunt Josephine good morning I
am stefano he's afternoon and surecount
Olaf
the only reason I can a life hasn't torn
you limb from limb is because he hasn't
gotten ahold of your fortune
you'll never get away with this of
course you will be mine
carpe diem seize the children tease the
day I said day
[Music]
whose skies smiling at me nothing but
blue skies
violet Klaus and sunny were intelligent
children most everything that happened
to them was rife with misfortune and
despair your parents have perished in a
terrible fire perished means killed we
know what perished means hello hello
hello children I am Count Olaf your new
Guardian you know what this is it looks
like a list wrong it's a list a list of
chores we know you're just trying to
steal a parents fortune we have to get
out of this wretched place go back at
the house where it's safe and strangers
can't get you strangers where the
Baudelaire children will be destroyed
hmm
when the sand runs out that fortune is
mine I didn't realize the Sun went so
quickly I bought it online you're gonna
need to flip it a couple of times your
parents and I we should develop our own
secret codes
our parents develop secret codes in my
library you will find all the answers
that you need let's get to work
something strange is going on what's
there something my parents had it looks
like the tattoo Count Olaf has on his
ankle
my name is captain chefs manager uli
Count Olaf in disguise aren't you smart
wherever you go I will hunt you down why
do you hate us so much because it's fun
we are setting out on a very top secret
expedition what do you say Baudelaires
are you in
[Music]
I'm taking you to prison well good luck
with that I'm armed
so my child's play adorable hmm
our pool gun
you